SPEAKER: You are
the enemy of the people!
SPEAKER 2: Right through!
It's coming through!
REPORTER: We are live
on the air at the moment.
Do you mind telling me
why I am under arrest, sir?
REPORTER 2: That reporter was
just taken into police custody,
live on television.
♪ (DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
CARL JUSTE: As journalists,
we can't let the truth down.
We are moderators of fact.
SPEAKER 3: Governments attacking
journalists is not new.
Oh, look at all the fake news!
ALL: (CHANTING)
CNN sucks! CNN sucks!
This is happening widespread,
also.
The president of Brazil
is saying that I am a whore.
SPEAKER 4: In the constitution,
freedom of the press
is guaranteed,
but the rules are changing.
SPEAKER 5: The problem is
the lack of public trust
in journalism.
I'm not gonna buy a newspaper
that doesn't reflect my views.
SPEAKER 6: It sometimes feels
like when you talk to people,
you're living in
two different realities.
If you want to talk to me,
you can take the mask off.
SPEAKER 7:
You can never tell what threats
are gonna materialize
on the ground.
(SPEAKING IN SPANISH)
JUSTE: In my 30 years
of experience,
I have not seen this amount
of harassment.
It's not even harassment,
it's intimidation.
It's so difficult to know
if this is the end of an era,
or the beginning of
something even more sinister.
(CROWD GASPS)
SPEAKER 8: Press freedom
in the United States
is starting to look like
many other countries
around the world.
That profound crisis
is not going away.